빌딩과 관련된 모든 일들을 저희가
원스톱으로 진행하고 있기
[음악]
때문에네 안녕하세요 bsn 있니다
제가 오늘은 저희 bsn이 무슨 일을
하는지 모르시는 분들이 있더라고요
그래서 bsn이 무슨 일을 하는지
여러분들한테 오늘 좀 소개해 드리도록
하겠습니다 어 우선 bsn 빌딩과
주택을 중계하는 업무를 시작으로
부동산 중계와 관련된 모든 서비스를
다 원스톱으로 하고 있습니다 그래서
bsn 연락 주시면 공인중개사
자격증이 없는 중개 보조원이 아니라
자격증을 갖추고 있는 공인 중개사를
담당자를 배정해 드립니다 그래서
담당자가 모든 일에 다 관여를 해서
좀 도움을 줄 수 있게 어 좀
믿음직스러운 그런 담당자를 좀 배정해
드리고요 담당 공인중개사와 미팅을
진행하고 매물을 뭐 제한적으로 몇
건만 보는게 아니라 매물을 찾을
때까지 담당 공인중개사가 적극적으로
좀 찾아드리고 있습니다 그리고 이제
매물을 보는 거에 대해서 따로 제한을
두거나 상담비 발생하지 않습니다네
그리고 매입하기 전에 신축이나
리모델링이 필요한 건물이 있는데
그거와 같은 경우에는 저희 자체적으로
건축사 사무소란 건설사가 있어서
매입하기 전에 사전 검토를 하실 수가
있습니다 그리고 보통 이제 건축 같은
경우에는 면허가 없는 경우가 많거든요
근데 저희 bsn 건축사 자격증과
종합 건설 면허를 보유하고 있습니다
이렇게 사전에 좀 건축 검토가 끝난
다음에 매매기 을 체결하고 난 뒤에
공사와 관련돼서 되게 좀 두려운
부분이 많으실 텐데 그 과정까지 그
담당 공인 중개사가 맡아서 적극적으로
좀 도와드리고 있습니다 그리고 공사와
관련된 그런 과정들을 봐 줌으로
인해서 따로 컨설팅 비용이 발생되지
않습니다 저희가 공사를 워낙 많이
해봤기 때문에 싸온 노하우들이 좀
많이 있거든요 그런 노하우들을
공사하는데 있어서 최대한 접목시키려고
노력하고 있습니다 그리고 공사 중에는
저희가 매일 공사 일보를 어 공유를
해 가지고 어떻게 공사를 했는지 어떤
자재가 들어왔는지 인원이 몇 명
투입됐지만 나 들어와 있는지 그런
과정들을 매일같이 저희가 공사 일보로
공유를 하고 있습니다 그리고 공사하고
나서도가 되게 중요합니다 보통은
시공사가 as 안 되는 경우도 많이
있거든요 전화를 진짜 안 받는다든지
저희는 전단 침을 뿌려 가지고
정기적으로 저희가 검사를 해서까지
완벽하게 좀 진행하고 있 습니다
그리고 공사하고 나서도 임대 현수막도
미리 좀 제작해서 공사하고 있는
도중에 이제 부착을 해서 임대 지금
진행도 같이 하고 그리고 만약에
필요하시다면 저희 관리팀 있습니다
bsn 케어 팀이 만약에 맡기시기
된다면 건물주가 하실 일들은 없어요
매일 매월 이제 보고서 받으시면 되고
그리고 중간중간에 문제가 발생되면
저희 관리팀이 현장에 가서 다 처리를
합니다 보통 bsn 케어 같은
경우에는 한 두 세 명이 한 건물에
이제 붙어가지고 전담해서 빌딩을
관리해 드리고 있고 정말 믿을 만한
어 bsn 좀 선택해 주시면 어 정말
후회하지 않을 거라고 저는 생각을
합니다 오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요 어
다음 시간에 뵙겠습니다
감사합니다